hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich war heute mal wieder in den
youtube trends unterwegs und habe dort
auf platz zehn
dieses video hier entdeckt vum tour tag
eins von und dann habe ich mir gedacht
wenn er seinen hund schon auf mehrere
tage auf teilt muss die bude auf jeden
fall geisteskrank sein von daher schauen
uns das ganze heute einfach mal
gemeinsam an und deswegen schauen wir
uns das ganze dann heute jetzt mal
gemeinsam an halo knubbel allein dafür
kriegst du schon daumen hoch simon das
hier ist eine kleine wand heckrotor der
endlosen kann mit dem umzug haben kein
vermieter zu schneiden sich auch mal
drauf kommen können ich bin ja selber
auch vor zweieinhalb monaten umgezogen
von köln nach hamburg und habe in der
zeit dann einfach fast gar keine videos
gemacht
er hätte eigentlich auch und videos
machen können aber ich habe mir das
lieber eine pause genommen und dann in
um zu geringe nämlich an bei unserer
tief gerade das ist unsere einfach die
ihr rad schon zum teil gesehen habt und
das ist unsere tief
moment
wenn das deren tiefgarage ist heißt es
ja dass die dort alleine wohnen ich bin
leider komplett raus was das ganze
madeira thema angeht ich habe nur damals
mitbekommen dass er ein haus am bauen
war und ich denke mal das ist es dann
also ich glaube jetzt mal nicht dass es
sich hier um eine wohnung handelt wenn
er die komplette tiefgarage versichert
aber wir schauen wir weiter das ist ein
auto von dem handwerker noch da ist das
ist ein auto das hier vielleicht kennt
keine ahnung dem gast gehört
hier könnten aus dem treppenhaus videos
und gehen politiker auf die erdgeschosse
also waren wir waren gerade kräftig - er
hat einen fahrstuhl
im haus das sind goals das hier ist der
erste vor von hier aus kann man schon
einen kleinen eindruck vom garten
bekommen und hier sind 62
mit diesem ersten haus wo wir uns ja
alle wohnung gekauft
[Musik]
immer wieder wohnungen hätten sie denn
gern
alle
krank
man kann ich in die kommentare
alle menschen das hier ist das
gästezimmer simon ohne so dann haben wir
hier die gästewohnung mir gefällt die
atmosphäre sehr und die aussicht ist
einfach unbeschreiblich
ich fühle mich schon ein bisschen brooks
simon ich mache eine rundtour wie viel
boden will zu filmen simon simon normale
menschen vor ich würde gerne ein haus
haben und ich kaufe mir ein geiles
mehrfamilienhaus ich habe nicht mehr
genug geld für den guten pc onkel ja wir
wollten eigentlich zwei häuser bauen
heftiges haus aber wo sind die
einbauschränke ohne einbauschränken
youtube deutschland gibt es nicht mehr
aber das hier ist die wohnung von meiner
schwester ich muss aufpassen dass ich so
filme weil natürlich noch alles sehr
ich muss aufpassen was ich filme film
direkt komplett die aussicht aber na ja
gut ich meine sind auf madeira ich
glaube das ist jetzt nicht so krass wie
wenn man in deutschland in einer
großstadt irgendwie raus filmt und dann
hat man direkt mehrere zuschauer täglich
vor der tür stehen aber er muss
aufpassen dass der film das heißt wir
werden wahrscheinlich nicht alles sehen
heute die hat hier eine garten wohnung
weil die hat die katzen dahinter ist ihr
also ist die küche da hinten ist ihr
badezimmer das ist das schlafzimmer
das zeigt welche ausführlich wird nicht
so wichtig
und das soll überhaupt nicht negativ
klingen aber genau da ich hab ich ja bei
babys haus auch gemacht weil ich ja
selber architektur studieren wollte
finde die wohnung ein bisschen verbaut
allerdings
dick da natürlich jeder mensch anders
viele menschen wollen halt ihre
abgetrennten räume haben so bei mir habe
ich relativ viel einfach offen gemacht
habe ich wohne ja auch alleine drin aber
ist halt geisteskrank dass die alten
kranken aussicht hat der kranke aussicht
hat + garten
du hast ja eigentlich nie 'ne geile
aussicht mitten im garten direkt in
einem zimmer verbunden weil das ja
meistens musste höher sein für eine
geile aussicht aber das war die wohnung
von seiner schwester auf jeden fall
nimmt er seine ganze familie jetzt damit
hinter oder was ist seine mission da
jetzt genau die andere additive bogen
von meiner mama und zwar haben wir hier
reinkommt ok schon mal kurz zurückgehen
hat man so schön
ja dieses kleine diese kleine holzoptik
und dann habe ich angebracht denn hier
war so ein richtig unnötige säule mitten
im raum richtig so richtig unnötig angst
haben dass ein bisschen mit dem partner
klein holzpaneele verkleidet als
minister 7
es ist haben wir noch eine säule oder
also klar wir uns tragen ist kann es
natürlich nicht wegmachen aber haben sie
auf jeden fall gut gelöst und auch mit
dem ganzen holz das passt auch richtig
zu simon finde ich also sollen holz also
ich meine ich hab auch überall holz in
meiner wohnung im unterzieht das sind
zum breiten vielen weil ich das
komplette haben wollte so ein holz ton
zum beispiel würde ich mir nie auf den
boden legen dass wenn dich zu dunkel
aber es hat auch wieder geschmack sagt
generell aber ich glaube das wisst ihr
auch ist natürlich keine aussage von mir
irgendwie böse gemeint sind alles nur
geschmackssache nicht wir sind uns alle
einig dass alles was die man jetzt schon
gezeigt hat sich keiner von uns leisten
könnte aber ich glaube wenn ich die
möglichkeiten hätte mit dem geld was
simon alles hat hätte ich ein bisschen
anders gemacht aber es sind einfach nur
geschmäcker hier ist die firma jetzt
eine offene küche mit einer schönen
titel ist geil holzdekorationen hier die
noch regale
hier sind zwei hunde knöpfchen denn
meine schwester nichte die katzen drüben
für den garten und meine mama nimmt die
hunde hier für diesen garten wenn wir
die haben
und katzen jetzt alle zusammen
bofa stehen die sich denn alle ich bin
macht es vor
ich könnte auch gar nicht mehr
vorstellen meinen eltern irgendwie
direkt nebeneinander zu wollen oder so
weil dann glaube ich immer stress so ich
liebe meine eltern über alles und ich
bin richtig gern bei denen aber immer
reicht's dann auch und dass der garten
die beiden gärten sind sohn im haus so
kleine längliche zeit jordans quasi und
wir haben hier sonst hochbeet wo wir im
bereich straßenbau und verschiedene
kräuter gewürze gehören hängen da auch
das hier wird der hanfpflanze nimmt
maracuja pflanze watt ich habe eine
tomatenpflanze und dies gerade dabei zu
sterben weil ich die glaube ich übergebe
weil ich denke ich habe eine pflanze die
brauchwasser außerdem haben wir noch ja
so hänge pflanzen das sind
kletterpflanzen werden diese ganze beton
waren zu wachsen irgendwann und dann hat
man hier so ein richtig schöner kann man
ja richtig schöne da sind richtig schön
kosegarten wo man auch das ist richtig
geil
das hier ist wenn dir das hier das ist
ultra geil
das hier ist das geilste was ich bisher
bei irgendeinem youtuber in der ruhr
gesehen haben ob wirklich als baby im
garten gezeigt hat dachte ich mir so
also metallteile so perfekt angeordnet
überall wird an diesen pflanzen diese
perfekt zugeschnitten wandel garten muss
leben ein garten muss leben alter und
dieser garten lebt noch nicht so richtig
bei soll leben und das ist uns missionen
und simon da muss ich hier wirklich
popstar sprechen jetzt nicht mehr nicht
vorne hut vor dir das sieht geil aus
alter in diesem beton dann hinten mit
der natur mit dem weiten blick mit
wasser ich finde man braucht immer
irgendwie wassernähe deswegen bin ich
auch so froh gerade in hamburg zu leben
wo du wirklich die allzu hassen alles
mögliche retro-optik sichtbeton richtig
richtig geil so bis rustikal ist an hier
mit dem mit dem ich sag's wie seite
das holt mich komplett ab hier sehe ich
mich
sorry dass ich mich so krass freue aber
wenn leute bei interior und exterieur
und architektur sachen generell dinge
ähnlich machen wie ich sie auch machen
würde freue ich mich einfach irgendwie
keine ahnung sind nur geschmackssache
wenn ihr das nicht verhallt ist
natürlich völlig okay aus dem haben noch
ein badezimmer was dann mein bruder
nutzt und das surfen einen kleinen
bruder ist auch noch sehr leer
ich werde es nicht bezogen einbauschrank
bett und sache der problem mehr
bildschirme als ich alltag ich gesagt
was ich aber nicht mehr dass ich mein
bruder hat muss sagen die küche ich
liebe sie die küche ist eine liebe die
küche von meiner mama ist wirklich also
nur hammergeil ist noch nichts macht
nein das sind die beiden wohnungen im
erdgeschoss wir gehen weiter eine tasche
höher ins erster stopp wird in
gaststätten finden sich gästewohnungen
ja wir hatten es gerade schon einen
kommentar gelesen aber er hat wirklich
eine gästewohnung
bei mir hier in hamburg gerade das mal
wo ich ja auch das video aufnehmen das
ist halt einerseits eine aufnahme zimmer
aber auch ein gästezimmer
aha erste bett
aber wohnung aber bei simon macht es
natürlich auch sinn nicht mal der
wohnort madeira und wenn er besuch
bekommt bleiben die leute ja vermutlich
auch ein bisschen länger als einfach nur
eine nacht und dann ist natürlich schon
gut wenn du die nicht in seinem büro
irgendwie oder in deiner wohnung hat
spenden sondern halt in der anderen
wohnung wenn man die finanziellen
möglichkeiten hat wirklich das definitiv
auch so machen aber das ist wirklich
geisteskrank auf der essen tages auch
die wohnung meiner kleinen schwester
dass der dicke die gästewohnung wird
noch so aufgebaut dass man hier im
wohnbereich hat eine richtig geile
zocker area hat für konsole und so wenig
halt vergesse da sind das navi wir
trotzdem oben spielen kann werde ich die
nicht übel stören wir werden noch selbst
kommen
außerdem gibt es hier auch nochmal ein
stapel man manchmal das zimmer ist genau
mein bruder
hier gehört auch noch ein setup
reinkommen für gäste dran und hier ist
auch ein badezimmer das genau aufgeteilt
wie unten wie die wohnen hier schon
gesehen habe nur hier ist die wand nicht
eingerissen
ja das
sie kann
fechter sven ihr habt nicht eingerissen
ist normalerweise würde ich immer sagen
wann direkt einreißen bla bla bla bla
bla damit man halt offene räume hat und
so weiter und so fort aber wenn die
natürlich der fernseher stehen soll ist
eigentlich ganz gut
allein dass er gefühlt in jedem raum
irgendwie ein setup aufstellen will will
dann quasi immer gäste da haben und die
stream dann zusammen mit ihm oder was da
genau sein plan wir haben eigentlich
kosten für beide also dass wir unsere
familie ein haus wo sabine und ist dann
drin wohnhaus meine family krass
also seinem plan ist es wirklich seine
ganze familie nach madeira zu bringen
aber ist ja gar sein ja gönnen wenn er
sich da wohl fühlt und so weiter und so
fort für mich wäre es nichts ich weiß
auch dass meine familie sich total
wohlfühlt in deutschland aber wie gesagt
wenn und wenn man es machen möchte mit
auswandern dann soll man das auf jeden
fall tun wenn man da bock drauf hat vor
allem wenn die finanziellen
möglichkeiten hat dann zwei häuser zu
bauen also 1 für simon und seine
freundin weil es ist glaube ich
und nochmal für seine familie ist extrem
geil findet auch richtig krass dass
seine geschwister da auch so mitziehen
weil sie sind ja augenscheinlich noch
ein bisschen jünger und daher würde ich
halt auf jeden fall sagen nee ich will
wirklich in deutschland bleiben wenn
meine schulfreunde und so weiter und so
fort aber wenn die da alle happy meals
sind ist ja richtig geil vor allem die
lebensqualität haben muss ja so viel
geiler seien allein mit der sonne und
alles diese säule wasser ernährt und dem
weg haben auch diese neueste kreation
macht das ist sehr geil weil du hast
eine theoretische hinstellen
ich würde alles vollständig regalen und
anhalt für gästeschwund weiter und zwar
das habe ich bei mir in hamburg genauso
gemacht für ein shooting stars regal so
ich liebe kochen sind liebe dass er hier
zu stehen wenn da dann die kamera steht
hier so gerne mit euch zu kochen und so
weiter
macht simon koch streams dass unser
wohnzimmer die schale kaputt gegangen
hier kommt man zu unserem schlafzimmer
und unserem partner fernseher hängen
schon ehre fernseher im schlafzimmer
ja oder nein schreibt sie nun die
kommentare ich finde einen fernseher
gehört nicht ins schlafzimmer es ist
alles gerade noch ein bisschen
provisorisch aufgebaut gestern hat die
kamera noch dort hinten eine ecke stehen
da war ich zu weit weg ich habe ich kann
mich nach vorne wurde als motor kommt
noch mit monitorhalterungen an den tisch
und so weiter und so fort
es fehlt hier noch komplett deko
dasselbe
hal
aber das ist ungefähr der platz wo ich
ungefähr sitzen werde das wird
wahrscheinlich noch ein stück nennt man
simon als schiedsrichter
ungefähr ich kannte mal die
geisteskranken geistes gab es nicht von
meinem arbeitszimmer
also das ist
dann jetzt
vorbei
das ja das war doch ein entspanntes ende
für die hugo simon ich weiß jetzt nicht
warum das video so abrupt zu ende
gegangen ist aber hätte zu beginn schon
gesagt er dreht einfach in montevideo
mit seinem iphone mir als auf jeden fall
krass gut gefallen vor allem der garten
die aussicht und natürlich die generelle
lage gefällt mir am allerbesten auch
natürlich dass du direkt mit seinem auto
in eine tiefgarage fahren kannst wo er
halt irgendwie 40 stellplätze hat oder
so dann kannst du direkt mit einem
aufzug hoch fahren in die wohnungen ein
richtig richtig geil alles gut
durchdacht ich freue mich auch auf den
nächsten tag der wut uhr also es wird
der entscheidenden tag 2 3 4 5 tausend
kommen vielleicht kommt jetzt jeden tag
einen schuss von simon online wenn euch
meine reaktion darauf gefallen lassen
einen daumen hoch da simon falls du das
gesehen sollte ist ganz ganz liebe grüße
nach madeira
viel erfolg weiterhin für das projekt
liebe grüße an zubehör und
[Musik]